OK, today we have another concept question.
A contractor is building footings loaded equally in two different kinds of soil.
The project's timeline is lax, and mitigating structural failures is being prioritized,
so the goal is to have both footings achieve their long-term settlement at roughly the same
amount of time before continuing with the project.
Which footing should be built first?
So our options we can see over here for footing one and footing two are that footing
one is built on clay, and footing two is built on sand.
So footing one should be built before footing two.
Footing two should be built before footing one.
Both footing should be built at the same time, and it does not matter when either footing
is built.
Again, this is just a conceptual question, and the answer will be the first answer.
Footing one should be built before footing two.
And the only reason for this is that the long-term settlement for clay will take longer than
the long-term settlement for sand.
So building the footing on clay should begin first to give it more time to achieve its long-term
settlement.
And that's pretty much it for this problem.